[Musique]
nous sommes dans le billard au nord-est
de l'inde la région al indice de
fécondité le plus élevé du pays uche a
des vies est assistante sociale depuis
dix ans elle encourage les femmes de son
quartier à avoir moins d'enfants et son
travail commence à payer il y a dix ans
une femme de cette région rurale et
pauvre avait en moyenne plus de 4
enfants contre trois aujourd'hui
donc il est mignon
maintenant que tu as eu ton premier
enfant
tu en veux d'autres
enfin maintenant tu peux utiliser des
préservatifs ou la pilule tant que ça
marche
oui tu dois prendre des précautions je
vais apporter tout ça est bien expliqué
ensuite tu pourrais utiliser ces
méthodes dont en trois ans pourtant
deuxième enfant d'ici là un soin de toi
et de ton petit
ici comme partout dans le pays ce sont
les femmes qui portent la responsabilité
du planning familial
c'est mieux d'avoir une plus petite
famille ça nous permet de mieux éduquer
nos enfants et de les envoyer dans de
meilleures écoles on peut bien les
nourrir
une famille nombreuse c'est plus
compliqué c'est la galère
pour aider ces femmes à avoir moins
d'enfants ufat leur suggère une méthode
radicale est irréversible la
stérilisation
je recommande la stérilisation une
opération il même les hommes peuvent le
faire même les sommes d'accord
la blague il supporte à peine la vue de
son propre sang tu me fais rire
dis à ton mari que s'il ne te laisse pas
te faire opérer qu'il le fasse lui la
stérilisation masculine est plus facile
si quelqu'un doit le faire je sais déjà
que ce sera moi
il ne donne pas assez pour éduquer
beaucoup d'enfants avec l'inflation les
familles commencent à se rendre compte
qu'elles ont intérêt à n'avoir que deux
enfants et se concentrer sur l'éducation
pour leur assurer un avenir
les enfants doivent pouvoir devenir
indépendant pour éviter de devenir une
charge pour les parents
en inde plus d'un tiers des femmes
mariées en âge de procréer font le choix
de se faire ligaturer les trompes une
opération irréversible
loin de faire l'unanimité dans un pays
où contrôle des naissances rimait avec
stérilisation forcée dans les années 70
mais aujourd'hui beaucoup de femmes
utilisent cette méthode contraceptive
pour se libérer de grossesses non
désirées
alpes ain à 38 ans et sa belle soeur
rade à 26 ans ont tout deux eu leur
premier enfant à 16 ans j'étais mariée à
15 ans et à 20 ans j'avais déjà trois
enfants
nous avons été mariée très jeune et nous
avons et des enfants beaucoup trop tôt
notre corps et notre santé en souffrent
aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que je me suis fait opérer
je veux pouvoir éduquer ma fille et me
concentrer sur son avenir
je ne veux pas qu'elle ait la même vie
que moi elles méritent mieux
les dernières générations d'indiennes
avec de nouvelles aspirations semblent
contribuer à un meilleur contrôle
démographique
maintenant les femmes se marient de plus
en plus tard à 26 28 voire 30 ans elles
ne veulent qu'un ou deux enfants et ont
de plus en plus leur mot à dire bientôt
elles n'auront plus besoin de recourir à
la stérilisation
si la baisse du taux de fécondité indien
témoigne de progrès sociétaux le recours
massif à la stérilisation féminine
révèle un manque d'information sur les
autres moyens de contraception
beaucoup de femmes qui se font
stériliser le faut probablement en se
disant qu'elles ont eu des enfants et
que ça leur permet une contraception une
bonne fois pour toutes si j'ose dire
ces femmes ans qu'on fait de
connaissances sur les possibilités et
mode d'emploi d'autres contraceptifs
le gouvernement incite aussi ces
travailleurs sociaux à convaincre les
femmes de se faire stériliser nishi donc
beaucoup de ces femmes ne font pas un
choix éclairé
selon une étude publiée il ya quelques
semaines le taux de fécondité en inde
est tombé pour la première fois deux
enfants par femme sous le seuil de
renouvellement des générations
peut-être la promesse de meilleures
conditions d'existence dans un pays où
plus de 200 millions de personnes vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté